you're watching one piece oh my god yeah
why
what's wrong with one piece are you
serious
luffy is like the most boring character
there is
he's just so simple and stupid i
personally think asta is a way better
character or
deku or what about
[Music]
hello there boys and girls today i have
a special video for you
and no it's not because we just hit 100
000 on the channel what there will be
another video for that occasion
no today we're gonna once and for all
show all of these other naruto boys
all these deku nerds and all those asta
weeps
why luffy is objectively the best shonen
hero
there is and with objectively i mean of
course because i say so with dramatic
music in the background
now usually you come across two types of
criticism from people who haven't
watched one piece longer than 10 seconds
when it comes to luffy
luffy sucks as a main character or luffy
sucks as a person and of course
today we'll be proving them wrong on
both of these points
in this video i'll show you why luffy is
the best shonen protagonist from a
storytelling perspective
and then get into his character and what
in my opinion makes him better
than the rest in part two let's go
[Music]
okay so first of all let's start by
looking at the premise of one piece
according to john truby the premise of a
story is the entire story
boiled down to one single sentence it
should contain some sort of starting
point
some sense of the main character and
some sense of the ending
so all we pretty much have to do is boil
down roughly 1
000 chapters of story into one sentence
i'm gonna spare you the 30 minutes that
i try to phrase this correctly
you're welcome so the premise of one
piece i would say is this
a strong-willed and pure young man sets
out to find a crew and become the king
of the pirates
in order to find freedom in a world that
is ruled by injustice
and violence yeah i think that works
now on the most fundamental level the
premise is the most important part of
the story
what you write about is way more
impactful than
how you write it and what makes a good
premise good
is not only an interesting setting and
idea but especially a main character
that goes hand in hand with the plot and
this
is what achirauda did with one piece
luffy makes the story better and the
story
makes luffy better they organically
enhance each other
let me explain as any good story one
piece has an underlying message that the
author wants to convey
now one piece as you know has many
leading themes like
friendship love justice
adventure dreams it's a long list that
i've discussed in more detail in my
iconic scene analysis series
but what is the main the big the
overarching theme of one piece
[Music]
exactly oda has integrated all of these
other ideals and values
in the fundamental message of one piece
why
freedom is so valuable and why you
should fight for it
the freedom to do what you want the
freedom to
go where you want to go the freedom to
be
unharmed and heard by others but most
importantly i guess
the freedom to be yourself i personally
think that it's absolutely clear that
luffy's main drive and desire in the
story
is to reach that absolute level of
freedom now that may seem profound but
it's exactly the seamlessness that makes
the story work
so well because that theme of freedom is
woven into every single part of the plot
every single part of the world and in
each and every character in the story
you don't think about it because it's
everywhere
the entire story is taking place under
this premise
and we're basically like fish in the
water compare this to naruto naruto
naruto whatever for the longest time the
story makes us believe that this
is a story about how kindness and
courage will lead you to friendship
love and acknowledgement but suddenly
naruto
naruto naruto but suddenly
naruto is the child of prophecy which
basically completely
undermines this basic message which is
exactly why i think people were so
incredibly unhappy with its ending
and while naruto was clearly the
strongest ninja in the end
was he really the one that best
represented the theme of the story
with luffy oda chose the most
interesting and relevant character when
it comes to exploring
freedom luffy is the story
literally also i think now would be a
really good time to subscribe to the
channel one moment there
what about all those weird looking
villains that one piece has that guy
they're
so not badass
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
but not only luffy embodies the central
moral arguments
all of the villains and antagonists that
he faces along the way
as diverse as they might look and as
different their ambitions might be
all of them without any exception i can
think of stand
opposed to the ideal of freedom in some
way or form
villains like crocodile and doflamingo
who control and manipulate entire
countries
villains like caesar who capture
children to experiment on
or magellan who literally runs a prison
villains like the tenryuubito will
literally enslave people and treat them
as objects
and even villains like katakuri who is
unfree to be himself and suppressed by
the high expectations of his family
let me tell you this consistency in the
main values and ideals that are clashing
in the story
is such a fundamental aspect of
storytelling
but really hard to do right and yet
neither the antagonists nor luffy ever
do
anything that really feels out of
character and strives away from these
ideals
this consistency represents luffy in
such a clear and
tangible way that it makes him a very
three-dimensional and very authentic
character
but even in his function as a main
protagonist luffy differs from the trope
of the typical shonen hero
typically we have the main character
that starts somewhere at the bottom
gives us the typical coming of age type
of story arc where the protagonist is
the outsider or
underdog and uses their talent or unique
powers to work their way to the top
goku wants to be the strongest asta
wants
attention i guess and naruto wants
acceptance
luffy however doesn't want to become
pirate king
for any of these reasons he simply wants
to be happy
and free and so i would argue that the
pirate king
is actually quite different from the
hokages and wizard kings out there
as they bind the hero's fulfillment to
external forces
when it comes to the pirate king it's a
goal that doesn't require him to become
the strongest with
crazy hidden powers but simply be strong
enough with the support of his crew on
the other hand we
also have the trope of the super
overpowered main character
that basically already is strong but has
to grow on a human level
and figure out a more internal struggle
examples here are characters like
saitama gong or soma
now while luffy is definitely way more
advanced with his powers at the start of
the story than a naruto or
deku he's also far away from being as
overpowered as this type of character
instead he's introduced with a
considerate amount of power
that then however is quickly tested by
stronger and stronger opponents
and open up a lot of room for growth
what makes luffy then
so different from other shonen heroes is
mainly his main character arc luffy
doesn't have to grow up
and prove himself to others compared to
the sasukes and bakugou's out there
he is deeply respected by his crew and
those around him
luffy actually starts the story not as
the underdog
but as the captain recruiting other
people to his cause
in other words his character arc is not
that from boy to man
but from a man to a leader luffy's
underlying arc to achieve his goal
is to become a better leader and captain
now given the length of the story this
development is admittedly quite slow
which makes moments like saba odi or at
marine fort even more impactful to the
reader
losing his brother luffy doesn't
suddenly unlock his
dark gear 6 devil awakening
but breaks down in shock and trauma as
a real person would now don't get me
wrong i don't think either approach is
better or worse than the other
what matters is that this unique arc is
completely
aligned with the premise of the story
that's why it works so much smoother
than many other popular shows i think
i would say that simply from a story
structure the setup and premise for his
character
puts him way over other shonen heroes
i mean look at this
this is just completely different
this is the story this guy unites
everything that one piece is about
in other words the best shonen
protagonist out there
[Applause]
okay you know what you may be right from
a storytelling perspective
but luffy is just so dumb and naive
how can you funny you should mention
that because we'll be discussing luffy's
personality
in part two wait you were about to watch
something else weren't you gotcha
well i recommend you watch this video
here
next thanks naruto
naruto naruto
is it what is it naruto naruto
naruto [ __ ]